when you were a waiter you would eat
people's meals that something went awry
something went wrong you like how how
did you do that so I mean I obviously it
wasn't a very good waiter sometimes I'd
put in the wrong orders but the chef
that was in this restaurant I was
terrified of him so instead of going
back and being like oh sorry I got the
wrong order I'd sneak it past them and
into the kitchen
but I didn't want to throw it out so I
just eat it
um yeah now you're from Scotland there
we go specifically I know right just
just a mysterious cloak
Healthcare I'm gonna come sit on the
floor with me
I'm coming down with you um okay I can't
cross my legs really I by the way I know
I'm just gonna slip okay sorry
um what this is a traditional Scottish
dish it is indeed what is it called it's
just neeps and thighs nips and tatties
that sounds like so this is
okay so it's basically it's potatoes and
rhubarb no
parsnip oh my God this is incredible
what is it is there a Scottish person in
the audience that can help me
it's rutabaga it is rutabaga so normally
what we have with this is normally High
guess leaps and tire is so basically
what haggis is is yeah what is it
because it's it's rough it's rough right
it's like
um
sheep's lungs if I'm ever reincarnated
and never want to be a sheep in Scotland
and what else is it and then it's like
oats and stuff it's like it's really
nice if you don't know what it is right
like a hot dog if that's what we got in
America we call that a hot tub a hot dog
[Applause]
yeah why is Scotland so cool I'm always
pushing stories on the news about
especially Edinburgh
um last night I found a news that
they're coming up with a plant-based
treaty to become more you know
eco-friendly save the Earth they also
have free pads and tampons for women
um first country in the world the the
advert the commercial for it it was my
little sister no yeah yeah okay crazy is
that
yeah
we got it they got it going on I mean
the food's questionable but I was gonna
say you don't want to be a sheep if you
want to be a human and Scott exactly
well after like you know we talk about
meaningful important familial taking
care of women
um and and food everybody at the end of
that needs some Gossip Girl people love
this world it's fun how have you liked
doing the show I loved it honestly it
was amazing like I I lived in LA and I
wasn't the biggest fan so it was an
amazing opportunity to come out to New
York and I'd filmed in New York I did
High Fidelity and I fell in love with
this city with Zoe Kravitz it was a way
and I just was looking for an
opportunity to come and Gossip Girl came
up and I jumped at it and yeah this is
home now for sure I was gonna say is it
true that you moved to Brooklyn yeah I'm
in Brooklyn I'm in Williamsburg and I
just fell in love with it I can't
imagine living anywhere else
let's take a look
Max uh just in time to choose dinner
when when our Bonnies I vote how about
this morning I I don't want anything to
be weird
neither do we which is why I'm saying
this while I still have the courage
I love you
both of you I said it and I meant it and
I'm saying it again
okay
you go
okay your character is in a throttle yes
or no would you ever do that in real
life no way I can hardly look after
myself yeah I just I can do it
I'm with you it intimidates me yeah so
much so stressful oh God can you imagine
nope okay well thank you so much for
coming on the show as someone who has
just loved you for what is definitely
over a decade thank you thank you
oh thank you
[Applause]
thank you Thomas um the season two
finale
finale up next
[Music]